on a very warm welcome indeed to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that and my guest
today is a woman who loves books and who
loves style what's more she's made a
very successful career and it seems a
wonderful life out of combining the two
and here she is and Gillick at Asha
thank you very much for joining us here
today on giving me great stuff
lovely now together with her former
husband Benedikt Taschen Angelica was
for two decades at the helm of the
global publishing phenomenon called
Taschen books
more recently Angelica has set up her
own publishing house and Gaelic a books
which is based right here in Berlin but
this very busy woman is involved in many
other projects and I'm sure she's going
to be a fascinating guest and Gil occur
I said there in my introduction books
and style are the two big things in your
life they is it fair to say they're the
two big loves of your professional life
yes I I think I made out of my passion
my profession yeah my big passion is art
and architecture yeah and somehow it
goes into style and you are looking at a
lot of beautiful things you develop
certain style I think I was going to ask
you because I mean books we'll talk
about books a lot later we'll talk about
you know it's it says it actually says
on your website and Gallagher has books
in her jeans and I think that's true
because of your family background which
we'll talk about but let's just talk
about style first your fascination with
style when did it really really begin I
would say very early as a teenager
already I was quite aware what I want to
heaven but I don't want to wear kind of
fights with my mother but yeah but it
takes the time to develop your own style
and to understand yourself what is
suitable to you and what corresponds
with your ideas yeah mm-hmm what why is
style I mean you know some people would
say we live in a world where there's you
know the people are at war people live
in poverty style
why is style important to me
I think Dostoyevsky I think it was the
CST who said beauty will save the world
I think beauty is something very high
spiritually and it's not such as only
superficial thing gasps oh and I think
the more beautiful things you bring in
the bird the more beautiful the work
becomes even there is poverty and war
and all the bad things okay
you want that argument it's style is
style the same as fashion or is there a
difference no style is a more broader
thing fashion is something like from
season to season but also this in
fashion you can have style but to have
style is also about manners about how
you live how you eat
give me style is something much more
bigger mmm you you've certainly got your
own distinctive style which i think is
quite consistent when I sort of said you
know it looks at look to lots of images
of you this past week of course and I
just wonder when you because you always
say it's very sort of spontaneous your
look yeah I don't know whether I should
believe that or not when you got up this
morning you know you were thinking oh
I'm going on talking Germany with mr.
Craven how much time did you spend sort
of thinking about your look actually I
didn't think too much because I just was
wearing what I was there in the last two
days and I was feeling comfortable and I
think this is the essential thing about
having your own style is to feel
comfortable and not to feel your clothes
yeah I just want not to think about it
and then simplicity is a recipe so the
less you do it the more simple it is the
more comfortable I fear okay
that's the message you've had your first
impressions there from Angela Kitaj in
here is more
Paris 2008 publisher Angelica Taschen
was on a voyage of discovery looking for
showy apartments for an illustrated book
for Taschen publishing house now 54 she
worked for Tushin for 24 years first as
an editor later as managing editor
Taschen publishes a wide range of
illustrated books not only on art design
and architecture but also on sex and
even cosmetic surgery
together with Benedikt Taschen who
became her second husband she made
passion books the world's largest
illustrated book publishers a Gaelic a
Taschen comes from a family of
booksellers she grew up in Cologne at
first it looked as if she would break
with family tradition she trained as a
classical ballet dancer but she was too
tall to be a prima ballerina
instead she studied art history and
signed up with dashing books after
separating from Benedict she went her
own way and founded her own small
publishing house in Berlin and today
she's our guest on talking Germany on
Gaelic attetion
some wonderful photos from your your
childhood days there yeah and Gaelic I
said at the beginning of the show you've
you've got books in your jeans yeah
you've got books in your DNA and it's
it's really true because you come from a
publishing family and it goes back a
long way yeah actually publishing is
true it was bookshop family it was found
at 1872 by my great-great-grandfather
1872 yes yeah in Bonn and it's still
there and my sister and maybe still
owned it mm-hmm but we don't run it and
yeah so I really come from and at in the
beginning it I still have the founding
document and it says book shop and
auction house actually well and they
were also but it was before the Second
World War there were also publishing
books hmm okay so you come from this
publishing family this is this family of
the bookshop yeah but you wanted to
become a dancer yes dance opera singer
who who I didn't know about that but
father opera my voice I found out it was
not working but I started studying
ballet and that was my really biggest
passion there was a problem though in a
problem that I'm not quite sure that I
mean you know pardon my ignorance but
you you were too tall yeah yeah what's
the problem with being too tall yeah
then you want to become or I was trained
becoming a classical ballet dancer you
cannot become so tall its 168
centimeters and how tall are you
176 oh yeah and because then you have
few dance on your toes you are even
taller and the men get only actually
they have you know there are a lot of
who say they have to carry you and you
are too heavy a little big so forget it
and interesting later and today you're
wearing high heeled shoes you very often
do again something that I've noticed so
you actually heighten your height do you
enjoy being a tall woman finally I
became I started enjoying it I was
hating it until
was 25 yeah and then I started okay now
you make the best out of it advantages
when you are in the room you're a bit
taller you can see better and it's a
stronger presence in a way and I think
also I maybe it's the wrong impression
but sometimes it they take you a bit
more serious okay I'm taking you
seriously I want to talk about a serious
subject about dashing books yeah I mean
it was a huge publishing success we've
seen just tell me a little bit about the
formula it was sort of you you took art
books you talked or you took art
architecture design three areas that
have been sort of really in photography
they've been part of the academic the
intellectual world and you popularized
them and into the mix you through to
spice it all up you through insects as
well yeah that was the formula you know
content vice but the success of the
formula I think was was the distribution
we had that we didn't sell foreign
rights to other publishers but we did
everything by ourselves or to the
distribution system so we could make the
print run higher and the retail price
lower and that was the big success that
you got great books with good content
well-done content for a quite good price
because at that time out books were very
expensive
exactly and nobody could afford them and
we tried to make them affordable also
for students and younger people and yeah
and you succeeded absolutely because I
mean I was part of the sort of you know
I was that I was one of those people out
there buying Hill books and I would you
know I'd pick them up and I think these
books are very affordable yeah that's
precise everybody yeah okay so you went
V in Europe you had a daughter while you
were still studying so you were a young
single mum yeah maybe we'll talk about
that shortly
yeah there you went off to you you got
involved in fashion books it was a very
successful publishing business you went
to live in America in Los Angeles you
went to live in a fascinating house I
think we've got let's just have a look
and we've got a couple
photos from the house here in Los
Angeles and maybe you can tell us tell
us about the house
Angelica yeah it's a house built by John
Lord not in 1961 and yeah as you can see
it's standing only on one pillar and you
go in a little funicular up to here and
then you're enters will dispatch the
house and it's quite unique I would say
absolutely completely iconic iconic
house yes that's okay so you were you
were enjoying all the success you were
living in this amazing house in LA yeah
you knew everybody who was anybody you
had to become there's a word for what
you have become you become a celebrity I
think in in in a way yeah did it do to
you yeah I don't know other people would
have to judge about this it's not on me
but I tried to actually also because of
my divorce and so on I had to how you
call it reinvent myself and it's maybe
it kept me on the ground I hope that my
friends tell me my old friends I still
have friends from my teenage yes or they
still recognize me
it's always a very good thing a very
very healthy thing to the past yeah
okay you after the Los Angeles phase
yeah you then came to Berlin you came to
live in Berlin and you set up and gear
like a books yeah yeah then I came here
but yeah okay and the interesting thing
about Angelica books is that you it's
described as it as a boutique publishing
house what is a boutique publishing
house yeah it's so it's I published now
only very few books and very small print
runs it's like a boutique hotels they
are not in contrary to chain hotels they
have few rooms and are not like chains
hotels
and I just do very few books in very
small print ones we have one wonderful
example here that you brought along
today and
just tell us about this book here while
I sort of you know give the viewers the
opportunity to establish I'm gonna open
it to see what we find
let's cruise along a little bit from
that one actually we also have an
English enter and French version showing
the German version it's a cooperation
with the famous perfume publisher I
didn't I didn't know that there is
something like a perfume publisher to he
invites the great noses international
famous perfume makers to do perfumes for
his rhetoric my label and it's a very
interesting and he comes from a perfume
then dynasty yeah
his great his grandfather founded Dior
perfumes and yeah and it's also like in
my case it's in his genes producing
perfumes and it was a very beautiful
cooperation because I myself love
fragrances and I just think what he's
doing is very necessary it's like a
petit polishing what I do he does on the
field of perfume because we have all
these mass-market perfumes in the
duty-free stores like all the big
fashion brands do in my eyes cheap
smells and he is doing he's trying to do
more precious and the old-fashioned way
okay I certainly a wonderful wonderful
book and it's there and I'm really
grateful to have got to know Frederic
mother who was somebody who just hadn't
been familiar to me before
Berlin fashion now I'll say one word now
Malak Strasser yeah tell the world about
Alexstrasza yeah it became the last few
years like the the fashion street in
Berlin of the little boutiques little
concept stores but also Berlin labels
like dalla baleen run their shops there
so you have in one very idyllic street
actually it's very nice walk yeah you
have like 10 little great fashion stores
it's interesting because because when I
was thinking I was I was looking through
your book about Berlin Street style and
it was talking about how Berlin fashion
is very improvised very pragmatic very
low-key now I thought mulac Strasser
because I'd seen that in in in one
interview with you you had recommended
more like ties as a place to go in
Berlin and I thought you know when I go
down mullick Strasser yeah I see
Berlin style in all these shops yeah and
it looks to me like the clothes that I
can remember people wearing in the 19
late 1970s really yeah yeah people are
paying you know for the for this sort of
low-key Berlin fashion people are paying
hundreds of euros to look like in the
1970s no no I think it's always as you
know in fashion the 80s are have a
revival the sixties it's always about
revivals yeah but I think what you see
is like really the Berlin style without
any connections to any decades
I think they create something by
themselves and also because they do it's
a lot of handcraft
and it's it's not like H&M and Zara it's
a lot like small little enterprises who
do it and then anything if it don't
produce it in the form for how I say in
the east and design and so on it gets a
little bit more expensive but it's not
as expensive as it is the very big
brands in the report that we just saw
all the people who were wearing
in fashion were winning what about
Berlin men yeah actually I think there
are also P if he didn't do the little
book for women but you could do actually
a book about the Berlin man there is a
certain fashion style here tour as you
know many wear beard now and also you
know sneakers is a big subject you have
to wear the right curves because it's a
kind of coat yeah and they were Parkers
there is a certain style for men tool
yes you could do a book about it
actually - okay
maybe another project for you there when
you left LA you were very it was sort of
I guess and I've died I'm sure it was
the case he was you were financially
independent you could have chosen to
live anywhere in the world
yeah but for me this question was easy
normally I'm a bit like a [ __ ] should I
do this or that then you have too many
opportunities it gets difficult but in
this case for me it was very easy I
wanted to come back to Germany and
there's only one city for me Berlin and
I really fear and it's ten years now I'm
in the right time and the right place
for me like my Kundalini teacher from
Los Angeles she was just here you got
Kundalini yeah and she said in the
beginning of her workshop
oh my god the city is so ahead of
everything you have electric cars
everybody it's organic weeding food you
have homeopathy everybody is into an
alternative healing and so on and even
people from Los Angeles find that here
very
ahead of the time very beautiful from
Los Angeles ahead yeah talking about
being ahead let's go back in time just a
little bit can you remember because
you're talking about your relationship
to Berlin can you remember the time I
don't know before the Berlin Wall
definitely my grandmother was living
here and I remember my very first at
that time it was not cheap flying taking
our place
I took an airplane from cologne/bonn to
Berlin Tempelhof so my first very first
airplane flight was to Berlin Tempelhof
which is a quite impressing
yeah yeah I will my acquaintance is a
great piece of architecture yes and I
could feel it when I arrived at that
time my grandmother picked me up and I
remember this big which is still there
the monument in front of it yeah and
yeah and it's so my grandmother was
living in the fourth in the vest and but
she traveled with me you had to buy this
little visit
she showed me also the former East we
been to Alexander Platz and so on so
yeah so I know Berlin and then I was
later hitchhiking to Berlin back and
forth with my friends I spent a lot of
it we went to the jungle oh yeah and I
went to the jungle as well I always was
coming to Berlin since my teenage years
and I was were always interested okay 90
40 years of Berlin history no bit kind
of
and Gaelic are some very interested and
talented women there and we're talking
about families and work yeah when we
talk about families and work and we
talked about it being difficult it's
always a wound a problem for women and
lot of problem for men I think it's
still today the case even it's maybe a
little different time and getting a
little better the support for women who
want to work but I see it was my
daughter she has the same not problem
but the same situation mm-hmm so I have
two children and to be a doctor in a
hospital yeah and it's not easy yeah
it's a lot of stress and to combine both
things I think there it's not as
actually Germany a little bit
old-fashioned there perhaps I mean the
people always say that you know child
care in Germany it's not really very
well organized we tend to assume sort of
all too often that the woman will stay
at home and look after the kids yeah I I
don't know it personally
because I for example as France they
always say the women have it much easier
the child care is the state Publix the
child care is much better developed and
also I think the French woman has more
but that's only what I read but I think
you read it so often that there must be
something to about it they have much
more confidence to say I give my child
in very early age already to a
kindergarten and I go to my right back
to my regular work
I think it's they have a longer time
already doing it the German woman is
maybe not yet as used to this there's
always a conflict I feel they have a
conflict that they have to make a
decision and for the French woman it's
more clear that they want to do both
interesting comments what about you when
you were I mean you had one daughter but
there were other children running around
in your life I know and you were working
very hard with this global global
publishing Empire how did you combine
those yeah first of all I had no choice
or and I also think if I would have had
a choice I would not have been just a
mother because I have too many I'm too
curious and to me
interests and I like to work I loved my
book it was my passion and it's my
passion and yeah so I was lucky I could
do some how to it but I think it was for
my daughter not easy it was for me not
easy but in the end somehow it's
interesting that the women in our report
are sort of moving into what you might
call the second phase of their lives in
a way yeah and you you said something
interesting which I which I mean I noted
you said it not too long ago I used to
be frightened that when you get to 50
you no longer count neither in your
career nor in the eyes of men yeah has
that changed your perception on that or
you you said you know you're frightened
of that yeah I think you don't need to
be frightened to be I can say now I'm
not sure if I really said this but I
think the times really have changed yeah
because we get now in former times it
was used I over 70 now you become 90 so
you are in the middle of your life and
not in the last part of your life the
cause of our healthcare and all of this
and we know so much more about food and
I don't know any wrong nutrition
nutrition so we we get much healthier
much older it was much more energy and
we can do so much more and I think life
only starts assisity interesting talking
about progress being made in 2010 you
were a founding member of the German
branch of the International Women's
Forum yeah what was that all about
yeah and I'm also in another private
circle of women's Pro home yeah the idea
of this is to speed up the development
which is there that in higher positions
women
reflecting what is the population we are
half half and when you look in the
higher positions it's 1/4 of women if
you are lucky if you're very lucky if
you are very lucky and in certain fields
not one so we still have to work on this
yeah okay this is all has to do a
service to support each as ayah and
within the women but men do very
naturally if you women are that we have
to learn more
I suppose the big question the big
central question for somebody that I can
ask somebody like you is does German
culture need to be protected from
American business yeah I think we could
learn from each other it's not that one
needs to protect it that's the wrong
strategy yeah because I think the
Americans found a lot of good ways
supporting culture like the whole
private funding raising money for
institutions it works so well in the
states and we only have to stay taking
care of it and there is a totally
different culture between rich people in
the States and here and the other way
around maybe the Americans can learn
from European or especially German
culture supporting culture like TV the
book printing was invented in Germany so
I think it's a deeply rooted culture a
good a book and the Americans don't have
this deep roots and so maybe they don't
understand why we want to control book
price and so on so they exchanged what
reflections you talked about about how
good the Americans are at in through
private foundations investing money in
culture what the Americans are also very
good at is it is creating large
companies especially these days when we
you know in the report we heard about
Facebook and Amazon and so on and Google
of course and and we've talked about
Berlin and Berlin's often now viewed as
a sort of a startup City yeah and I
wonder what your because you you you
call yourself a sort of a cultural
entrepreneur I know is there any sense
that Berlin will be able to create a
company on that scale or is the Berlin
startup see just a lot of trendy people
sitting around in cafes I think yeah I
think Berlin could has a potential yeah
to develop something like that because a
lot of amazing international
people gather here come together develop
great ideas but then these ideas
products in the internet you can also
call it product become very successful
they are running away to other countries
where they find politically but also tax
wise better conditions to grow and to
become like really big
I think I'm not so into the details with
loss but I think there has to be a
little change to enable these great
start-ups this great ideas to grow
faster and easier okay interesting
thoughts but we're going to change the
tone just a little bit because we like
to ask our guests to bring along
cherished private possessions yeah and
you have done so angular core wonderful
you've brought along what I'm going to
use the German word you brought along
your test you yeah your teacup and
saucer yeah tell us why yeah since my
teenage yes I drink every morning my cup
of tea out of this tea cup which is from
cap am A Berliner kpms Kuna cliche
poison manufacturer the Royal Prussian
manufacturer yeah founded by Swiss team
course and this decor is from Ising 1760
and it's the since then I don't know how
many as 250 years in production and I
drink from a cup which was invented 250
years ago and I still enjoy it every
morning since many many years and what
did it actually come into your
possession how old were you when you
first yeah I would say so when I was
searching 14 because my grandmother was
collecting it already and she was giving
me as some as a present and then just
each birthday was each Christmas I got
one piece and so it grew over the years
and I still buy it when something breaks
and yeah I still enjoy it very much
I like the how you call it hi sauce yeah
you know I was taught but I'm not sure
if this was the
because the tea was so hot the Proteas
have you tried it do you actually do it
I don't do it but I I tried to wait and
but it makes sense right it makes sense
absolutely it's very lovely this this
KPM stuff is very under yeah yep the
very early days of your fascination with
the designer yeah Angelica we've just
got a little bit of time for our quiz at
the end of the show oh I can hear the
music what do we do I'm gonna give you
one question where are we more likely to
find you tucked up in bed reading a book
or dancing the night away finding me in
the bed reading a book even I love
dancing
there we go that's all the time we have
with the stylish with the bibliophile
trend-setting and charming angular cat
ashen a great guess if you've enjoyed
our company as much as I have then do
come back next week until then bye bye
and truce